Stephanie Grisham is the White House
press secretary and communications
director she joins us from Washington
Stephanie good morning thanks for being
here
good morning thanks for having me our
Ben Tracy reported in the first
half-hour that sources in the White
House told him that the president was
concerned about what impeachment means
for his legacy is he concerned
well he's talked about that before he
has said nobody wants impeachment on
their resume so I think that's not a
surprise to anyone however this
impeachment in particular is going to go
down in history as one that was done on
partisan political lines and it's
concerning for future presidents whether
there'll be Republicans or Democrats
because if this is the standard that
we're gonna have presidents can be
impeached by just having a policy
dispute and that's not good for the
country he seemed to recognize the
gravity of the moment in an angry letter
people called it scathing I rate to
Speaker Nancy Pelosi
how can he move forward given the way he
apparently feels right now well he has
been he continues to move forward I mean
we're getting us mca past we've got NDAA
going on that's gonna include parental
family leave which is going to be huge
he's been building up the military jobs
are great the economy is good he
continues to work while this is all
going on I wish that the Democrats would
follow his lead and do that there's so
much work to be done on behalf of this
country he's actually keeping the whole
White House very very focused we have
been very angry that this is happening
to not only our boss but our president
but he continues to move forward and
it's been really really inspiring to see
you know last night he told the crowd in
Michigan that this impeachment was about
them that the Democrats were out to get
them and Stephanie when you look at that
when you look at that that really is not
the case this impeachment process is
solely focused on the President of the
United States why does he keep saying to
the people who are listening to him that
this is really about all of us together
that's really not the case here doesn't
that put out a false message false
narrative about what this is really
about I think I would disagree with you
on that one
the minute that the president took
office the Washington Post had a
headline saying the calls for
impeachment for this president have
begun Democrats started calling for
impeachment immediately the president
was simply saying that this is bad for
the country that since he was elected by
the people of this country Democrats
have been trying to get him out of
office that is not good for a country
who voted him into office and for the
people who want him in in the White
House working on his behalf so it really
is about the American people because
they're trying to take a president down
ever since the 2016 election and they're
trying to stop him from winning in 2020
so that's that's kind of the message
he's trying to send there okay so to
hear people speak on his behalf
Stephanie Chuck Schumer as you may know
was here earlier he said he would like
to hear testimony from Mick Mulvaney
from John Bolton why not allow the
public to hear what people on the
president's team have to say about that
well we don't know what's gonna happen
yet and the President himself has said
that he would love for witnesses to
speak on his behalf because he did
nothing wrong the strategy isn't set yet
he's got a great team that will defend
him in the Senate but he's a over that
he can quit that's a phone call for him
to mitch mcconnell's saying this is what
I want to happen he certainly does it is
true yes absolutely but the rules
haven't been set yet and as you guys
talked about earlier Nancy Pelosi says
she may not even be sending these
articles to the Senate so we've got to
see what's gonna happen the Democrats
continue to change their rules they've
been doing that throughout this entire
process so it'll be difficult to get a
real strategy set until we have the
articles impeachment in the Senate and
Mitch McConnell has had a chance to
really look at what the fair just thing
to do will be do you think all the
Republicans will stay with the president
do you think there any possible
defection Stephanie no I don't this has
been incredible to see the Republicans
unify behind this president when you
truly look at the the evidence and the
transcript that the president he himself
released the Republicans know that he
did absolutely nothing wrong he had a
very normal conversation with a foreign
leader and the Republicans are just
really rallying behind him it's been a
great thing to say I think this is
actually better for our party and I
think that that's gonna show in 2020 I
think this is truly backfiring on the
Democrats the Republicans may be coming
together but the country certainly is
not coming together and the president is
out there calling Nancy Pelosi crazy at
a rally last night there was a tie rate
letter
can we see steps from the president
going forward as we did with Bill
Clinton an effort to bring the country
together to work on the issues that
mattered every day
Americans I think that again I would
take issue with the fact that you're
calling an irate letter he was laying
out his his case because he wanted unity
will we see an attempt to one side and
Democrats on the other has been working
towards unity he has been begging for us
MCA to get passed through the house
which is something that is great for
this country he's been working towards
NDAA which is for our military giving
them a pay raise and again parental
leave the president has had all kinds of
things waiting on Nancy Pelosi's desk
that could unify this country and show
that the two sides are working together
but they've chosen not to do that you've
got to remind you it's the the Democrats
that for the months and months and
months have done nothing but use the
word impeachment and try to divide this
country the president will do anything
he can to work alongside the Democrats
the Republicans to get things done on
behalf of this country it's America
first for him it always has been
did you cringe a little bit of his
comments last night in Michigan in John
Dingles home state who's considered a
bit of a hero there when he seemed to
imply John Dingell as you know is no
longer with us that he may be looking up
from hell didn't he I didn't hear him
say that but I will say that we we do
thank her for her service and we are
very very sorry for the passing of her
husband we thank him for his service the
president did do at her request all that
he could he lowered the the flag at the
White House did all that he could to
honor him you've got to remember this
president has been under attack now for
two and a half years tensions are high
the rally last night there was a lot of
a lot of passionate people and I think
that a lot of riffing was going on but
at the end of the day the President did
do all he could to honor her husband and
again we're very very sorry for the loss
all right Stephanie Grisham we thank you
for joining us he's doing stranger we'd
like to have you back again happy to do
it all right thank you thank you very
much